who has complained the most about their
NBA 2K rating obviously you saw the clay
stuff in the KD stuff last year Dion
Waiters would get on me all the time
every single year I think Katie's still
fired up that there are no 99s in the
game I will always hear from him Ben
Simmons is another one I hear about all
the time has anyone complained about the
rating and you listened and changed it
no we really keep the ratings sacred
like it's a really big thing it's a
formula that's based on the player's
performance you want to prove it out it
won't fall out on an NBA score that's
the way to get you ready what has been
the best or most unique bribe you've
gotten so far to improve either a player
or team's rating I don't want to go to
the number one but uh I'll go to the
number two I mean there's definitely
been like shoes like Grill shoes that
have been involved in conversations I
think people know that I'm a massive
Sneakerhead it's a good try it's a good
attempt I kind of want another thing no
I can't tell you you could Google that
one that's for sure